PASSED THE SPACE NEEDLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, JILLIAN.
YESTERDAY AT HIS FIRST PRESS
CONFERENCE, JOE BIDEN RESPONDED
TO THE SURGE AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER REFUSING TO ACCEPT BLAME
FOR A CRISIS ON HIS WATCH.
>> PEOPLE ARE COMING BECAUSE I’M
THE NICE GUY, THAT’S THE REASON
WHY IT’S HAPPENING, THAT I’M A
DECENT MAN BE OR HOWEVER IT IS
PHRASED, YOU KNOW, THAT’S WHY
THEY ARE COMING BECAUSE THEY
KNOW BIDEN IS A GOOD GUY.
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS, NOTHING
HAS CHANGED.
AS MANY PEOPLE CAME, 28%
INCREASE IN CHILDREN AT THE
BORDER IN MY ADMINISTRATION.
STEVE: WELL, OUR NEXT GUESTS SAY
THEY WITNESSED A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS AFTER TOURING TWO
DIFFERENT MIGRANT TEEN
FACILITIES IN THE STATE OF TEXAS
THIS WEEK.
HERE TO SHARE WHAT THEY SAW
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN VAN TAYLOR WHO
WAS AT THE SITE, THERE HE IS
RIGHT THERE IN DALLAS AND AUGER
LOOKINGER WHO WAS IN MIDLAND.
GUYS GOOD MORNING TO BOTH OF
YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> CONGRESSMAN, LET’S START WITH
YOU, JOE BIDEN SAYS I’M OPEN FOR
TRANSPARENCY, JUST NOT YET.
HOW BAD IS IT THAT HE DOESN’T
WANT US TO SEE IT?
>> STEVE, THE ONLY THING THAT’S
OPEN IS THE BORDER, WHICH WE
HAVE OPENED HIM REPEATEDLY TO
CLOSE.
AND IN THE COVER OF DARKNESS HE
ESTABLISHED A FACILITY IN
MIDLAND, TEXAS, WHERE THEY WON’T
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THERE IS A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY.
A DIRECTOR INSIDE THE FACILITY
TOLD ME THIS IS THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF TRAFFICKING IN HER
CAREER THAT SHE HAS EVER SEEN.
STEVE: OH MY GOODNESS,
CONGRESSMAN TAYLOR, JOE BIDEN
WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT WHY THEY
ARE COMING.
THEY ARE COMING AND HAVE YOU
HEARD STORIES FROM SOME OF THESE
MIGRANT CHILDREN THAT DOWN IN
THE CARTEL -- DOWN IN THE
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES, THE CARTELS
ARE ADVERTISING ON THE RADIO,
HEY NOW IS THE TIME TO GO.
LET’S GO, HOP ON THE BUS.
>> YEAH.
INTEREST THE CARTELS ARE MAKING
MONEY OFF OF THIS HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS THAT WAS CREATED BY
RECKLESS RHETORIC OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE LEVEL OF CRISIS THAT WE ARE
SEEING, THIS IS THE -- I MET
WITH THE COMMANDER OF THE
EMERGENCY INTAKE CENTER IN
DALLAS, TEXAS THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED AND WENT FROM ZERO
TO OVER 2200 CHILDREN IN SEVEN
DAYS.
I MEAN, JUST A DRAMATIC PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE, A CRISIS ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
AND THEY SAID THIS IS THE WORST
THEY HAVE EVER SEEN, YOU KNOW,
IN 30 YEARS OF WORKING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES, HANDLING ALL DIFFERENT
SURGES ON THE BORDER.
THIS IS BEYOND ANYTHING THEY
HAVE EVER SEEN.
AND THE ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY
OF FORT BLISS BEING USED IS JUST
A SIGN OF HOW BAD IT REALLY IS.
I MEAN, IT’S SO BAD YOU ARE
HAVING TO CALL IN THE MILITARY.
STEVE: CONGRESSMAN TAYLOR, YOU
LOOKED AT THE FACILITY IN
DALLAS, YOU KNOW, WE HEARD FROM
THE CDC REGARDING SCHOOLS, KIDS
CAN NOW BE 3 FEET APART RATHER
THAN 6 FEET APART.
HOW CLOSE ARE THE KIDS, THE
SLEEPING SITUATION, DESCRIBE
THAT?
>> I MEAN, THEY HAD THE WHOLE
FEMA COTS AND AGENTS ARE DOING
THE BEST THEY CAN.
THEY HAVE 500 PERSONNEL WORKING
FULL TIME IN THIS FACILITY IN
DALLAS.
AND THEY ARE SLEEPING LITERALLY
HEAD TO FEET.
THE COTS ARE JUST A FEW FEET
FROM EACH OTHER.
THEY ARE GOING AROUND IN PODS OF
50 TO GO GET LUNCH TO DO THEIR
5-MINUTE SUPERVISED SHOWER.
YOU KNOW, AND HOW THESE
FACILITIES DON’T BECOME COVID
HOT BEDS I DON’T KNOW.
I MEAN, BUT THEY ARE NOT
DESIGNED TO DO IT.
THEY ARE JUST DESIGNED TO HELP
THESE POOR CHILDREN TO SURVIVE.
AND THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS,
AGAIN, ON -- THIS ADMINISTRATION
CREATED IS ABSOLUTELY
HEART-BREAKING.
STEVE: CONGRESSMAN PFLUGER I
UNDERSTAND AND CONGRESSMAN
TAYLOR, WHEN THE KIDS COME HERE
THEY HAVE PHONE NUMBER IN THEIR
POCKET.
THEY HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT WILL
PRETTY MUCH FLY YOU ANYWHERE YOU
WANT TO GO IN THE UNITED STATES
JUST TELL US WHERE YOU WANT TO
GO AND WE WILL MAKE SURE YOU GET
THERE.
>> WELL, THAT’S RIGHT.
THEY ARE BEING COMMUNICATED TO
ALL THROUGHOUT THOSE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES.
THE PEOPLE THAT BENEFIT FROM
THIS ARE THE TRAFFICKERS, THE
CARTELS, THE COYOTES THE PEOPLE
MAKING MONEY AND THE CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
IT’S HEART-BREAKING FOR THE
CHILDREN.
AND YOU KNOW FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE NOT SAFE, THE CHILDREN
CAN GO WHEREVER THEY WANT
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THE
BORDER IS OPEN.
WE HAVE REPEATEDLY ASKED
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO VISIT AND,
YET, HIS OWN VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS MOCKING THE
SITUATION AT THE BORDER.
IT’S THE KIDS THAT ARE LOSING
AND HIS POLICIES HAVE
INCENTIVIZED THIS CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR.
STEVE: WE HEARD THIS WEEK THAT
AT LEAST ONE FACILITY IS AT
1556% ABOVE CAPACITY AND THAT
WOULD MAKE THAT A SUPER SPREADER
EVENT DURING A PANDEMIC.
IT’S JUST NUTS.